we
we're not violent we don't intend to be
violent the plan was never to be violent
we had a decision to make we had to make
this decision we want peace we want
happiness or what everybody to go home
really happy really peaceful so we said
you know what we'll do we'll postpone it
we all have freedom of speech but
however there's a time at a place for it
if I have something to say I can't just
go to a Metallica concert in front of
20,000 people in arena and start spewing
my invective at a concert like that if I
did so I would expect it to be injected
forcefully
potestas into up Chomp because the way
he like says things he could say it more
nicely but his points and what he wants
to do or good he just doesn't know the
right way to say it
you